it's official liberal justice stephen
breyer has announced his retirement from
the supreme court and president joe
biden has announced that he will not
consider any nominee to replace him who
is not a black woman
our process is going to be rigorous i
will select the nominee
worthy of justice briar's legacy of
excellence and decency
while i've been studying candidates
backgrounds and writings
i've made no decision except one
the person i will nominate will be
someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to united states
supreme court
it's long overdue in my view
i made that commitment during the
campaign for president and i will keep
that commitment
so there you have it joe biden will be
nominating
some black lady to the supreme court he
does not really care who the black lady
is doesn't seem to have much of a
preference
he is not suggesting any names
probably doesn't know very many if we're
being totally frank about it but that
doesn't matter to biden all he knows is
the sex and skin color of his nominee
and all i know is that whoever biden
picks groped me at a party in 2003. i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from robbie hobbs who
says it will be sad if a liberal black
woman is selected no one will believe it
because it was because of merit
she herself probably will have doubts as
she should it's pathetic that we're even
at this point selecting people based on
race and sex i was thinking that you
know if you make it to the supreme court
i guess you win i guess that's fine and
people are willing to put up with a lot
of of uh
losing their dignity of debasement of
all sorts of of struggle and suffering
to to get to that point but still
you think you're you're a woman
you've you've made it through your law
school through your career you've made
it to the point where you are even in
the running for the supreme court
and then the president who nominates you
says from the outset you are a diversity
hire it says from the outset we are not
doing this based on merit we are doing
this primarily based on skin and sex
that's got to be kind of annoying that's
going to be kind of upsetting to think
huh i i've worked very hard i'm a
talented person and the only thing that
the president sees about me is my race
and sex that's that's one of the real
downsides of identity politics now
fortunately i can tell you about a
wonderful upside that would be get
upside i am giving you money you're
welcome how do you get the money you
download the free get upside app you use
the promo code knowles and then whenever
you go to the gas pump you will get 25
cents per gallon cashback
except on your first fill up
then you will get 50 cents per gallon
cash back that's a lot of money people
who are driving a lot are making up to
200 to 300 a year cash back
i'm just handing you 200 to 300 you want
it yes or no you want to take it i would
especially now with gas prices going
through the roof there is no catch there
is only cash back you get the cash back
straight to your bank account or if you
prefer through paypal or amazon or an
e-gift card to some other shop
super easy just download the free get
upside app right now use promo code
knowles canadawles to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your first tank
that is code nulls i would just like to
say this off the bat i guess we are
breaking news right here
joe biden's nominee groped me whoever
she is she groped me i was terrified it
was horrible i was at a party and she
groped me and i it's traumatized me and
it's affected the course of my life and
if you give me a little while longer i'm
sure i can muster up some tears
i have exactly as much proof
that that happened as christine blasey
ford had about brett kavanaugh
so i just want that on the table now so
the journalists can start digging into
whoever the nominee is
she
totally groped me
and it was
terrible and she should not be on the
supreme court
okay
we've established that okay good
should we kavanaugh the nominee
should
and i'm not talking about boofing or any
parties with squi i'm saying should we
smear the nominee
dig through their personal life and
come up with some cockamamie story to
try to derail the supreme court nominee
i don't think we should lie the
democrats lied about brett kavanaugh
they just completely lied they made
stuff up they had zero evidence
we have no evidence that christine
blasey ford ever met brett kavanaugh
and then when you move
beyond
christine blasey ford to julie swetnick
that was the client of michael avenatti
the criminal lawyer i'm not saying he's
a criminal attorney i'm saying he's a
lawyer who also is a criminal and the
democrats had on their news networks
constantly julie swetnick who said that
brett kavanaugh ran some kind of
gang-raping underground
party uh
obviously there was no evidence
whatsoever that she ever met kavanaugh
that was completely discredited and with
christine blasey ford she never mustered
even one tiny shred of proof that the
two knew one another
should we do that to the democrats no i
don't think we should lie i don't think
that we should do something immoral
for a good end the good end being
keeping a liberal off the court
i don't think the ends justify the means
i'm not even saying we should make the
process a living hell
for
the
nominee
but i do think we should make it a
living purgatory
i do
i do
i think
that
we don't want to make it a living hell
because we don't want to put ourselves
in the position of the devil
but we should make it pretty hot pretty
fiery pretty difficult we should make
this
a truly miserable experience for whoever
the nominee is
and the reason for that is
it is the only way to make this process
better democrats started it democrats
are the reason that supreme court
nominations are so miserable they
started it with robert bork ronald
reagan's nominee for the supreme court
they didn't like that robert bork
disagreed with roe versus wade
meaning they didn't they didn't like
that robert bort was literate and that
he could read the constitution so they
hated that and ted kennedy stood on his
soapbox and said that in robert bork's
america women would be dying of back
alley abortions and he was a racist and
a this is nevadaist and this hideous
dishonest character attack on bork and
they get rid of pork now we have a verb
it's called borking when you bork a
nominee it's only gotten worse since the
next time we really saw this happen was
clarence thomas
clarence thomas who the the democrats
attempted to
lynch
in the metaphorical sense thomas called
it a high-tech lynching for uppity
blacks who in any way deemed to think
for themselves
then they did it again
obviously to brett kavanaugh a little
bit to amy barrett not as much
they've done this a lot the only way to
make this better is for it not to only
be one-sided if the democrats can't get
away with it they might think twice
the next time it's like the bully on the
playground
the way to stop bullying on the
playground
is not to never fight back against the
bully the way to stop bullying on the
playground is to punch the bully right
in the nose
and when you punch the bully right in
the nose you know what happens
you get less bullying
well it's the same thing here with
supreme court
nomination fights
when you
push back a little bit
when you give as good as you can get
on digging through the past on
the giving giving these people the
second degree then you have a much
better chance
of a more orderly and civilized
confirmation battle there's one last
point on the biden announcement
did you notice
the pronoun that he used can we play it
again let's play the joe biden
announcement again
our process is going to be rigorous
i will select a nominee
worthy of justice breyer's legacy of
excellence and decency
while i've been studying candidates
backgrounds and writings
i've made no decision except one
the person i will nominate will be
someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to united states
supreme court
it's long overdue in my view i made that
commitment during the campaign for
president and i will keep that
commitment
okay so you heard that that made perfect
sense to me and that person will be the
the
first black woman nominated to the court
but then when joe biden tweeted this out
he changed the pronoun
so the person i nominate to replace
justice breyer will be someone with
extraordinary qualifications character
experience and integrity and they will
be the first black woman nominated to
the supreme court
but you've already said it's a woman so
why don't you use the singular female
pronoun why are you using the plural
pronoun they will be the first woman
they their are their pronouns multiple
or do they identify as as having
multiple people in their heads and their
name will be legion for they are many
i don't think so why why the discrepancy
if i had to venture a guess i would
imagine that the person running social
media maybe is a little bit younger
than the person writing the speech
if i had to venture a guess because i've
seen this with a lot of millennials and
zoomers they will use they
as a singular pronoun not even the super
politically correct ones but other
people as well because because we all
feel these days that it is somehow
politically incorrect to use he as the
gender-neutral pronoun or she just say
they it's easier that way it blurs the
difference between men and women
this is one of the paradoxes of leftist
identity politics
on the one hand everything is about
identity the most important thing about
you is that you are a woman is that you
are black is that you are this is that
you are that
but then on the other hand nothing is
about identity and there's no such thing
as identity and men and women are
exactly the same
and all the races are exactly the same
and all the geographies are exactly the
same and all the countries are exactly
the same and all the cultures are
exactly the same and there's no
difference at all
it's this strange
duality
uh you i mean you really see it play out
with the lgbt movement on the one hand
we're born this way sexual desire is
immutable there's no changing it on the
other hand a man can be a woman and
nothing's real and there's 57 genders
and actually there are infinite genders
because it's all just kind of fluid man
why how does this make sense the the
only reason that makes sense is because
your identity comes from god whether
you're an atheist whether you're an
agnostic you might
not believe that god exists but he
believes in you
god is i am in the bible when moses says
who are you he says i am that i am
christ says i
before before abraham was i am i'm being
itself so if you find your identity in
god if you say man is made in the image
of god your identity makes sense
if not though then you're left with this
pathetic question who am i and you find
all these subsidiary sort of identities
but the problem is if god doesn't exist
then there's no meaning if we're all
just flesh puppets if we're all just
kind of moving around and all of the
things that we love and hope for and
desire are just illusions then nothing
really has meaning at all and identity
doesn't have meaning either and if a man
wants to chop himself up to look more
like a woman then sure i guess he really
is a woman because he doesn't there's no
meaning in his life
this is why this is one of probably the
most corrosive aspects of identity
politics
is you you have this huge swing from
everything is excessively about your
your identity characteristics but but
nothing means anything either and we're
all just kind of
babbling into the chaos
now if
senator mazie hirono speaking of
babbling and chaos if senator maisie
hirono is to be believed
democrat senator from hawaii
we can expect a very bad nominee for the
supreme court we have a number of really
highly qualified
black women and i very much support
president biden's decision to put a
black woman on the court high time about
time what i'm looking for is a justice
who can be fair and impartial and who
does not have any ideological acts to
grind which is what we saw
as far as i'm concerned and president
trump's nominees
including to the supreme court so yes i
am expecting a
fight but
there you have it and i'm looking for
someone who's going to be not only
highly qualified as all of the people
that you already talked about are but
who really brings to
the the judiciary the kind of diversity
that i'd like that uh
someone who will consider
the impact
the effects of whatever decision making
is on people in our country so that they
are not making decisions just based on
which i would like them to base it on
law which would be nice
and precedent and who are not eagerly
trying to get rid of decades of
precedent that would protect a woman's
right to choose for example and voting
rights etc but i'd like a justice who
also will take into consideration the
real life impact of the decisions he or
she will be making
you remember in school when a student
would get called on and the student
hadn't done the homework and the student
hadn't paid any attention in class and
the student would get called on and they
would just start
babbling they would just start and they
would contradict themselves and they
digress and they and they just try to
run out the clock
that's what you just heard
i'll try to i'll try to come up with an
analogy
let's say you had a pack of light bulbs
and some of the light bulbs because of
peculiarities of the manufacturing
process some of the light bulbs were
brighter than other light bulbs and
let's say you had
one light bulb that was the brightest of
all in the pack of light bulbs that
light bulb would not be maisy hirono
if you had a shed let's say a lot of you
probably have a shed outside of your
home
you've got you've got a lot of tools in
your shed right some of those tools
through use or manufacturing are going
to be sharper than the other tools
and so let's say you have one tool that
is the sharpest tool in your shed that
tool would not be mazie hirono
mazie hirono
is a little confused on a lot of topics
and here she has just contradicted
herself
many many times
she says
i want a nominee who is selected for
being a black woman i want a nominee
selected for under sex and under race
and i want the nominee to be
the top most qualified unbiased
impartial i want that i want the nominee
to be picked based on merit and also i
just want the nominee to be picked based
on her race and sex
you can't have both you can't have both
i'm not saying
that
black women
can't be the top of the heap they could
be
not saying that the top of the heap
can't be a black woman but i'm saying
that if you're if you are choosing one
priority over the other then necessarily
you're excluding the other right if
there's a conflict biden's going to go
with the black woman not with the most
qualified candidate
then it gets even crazier on the
contradiction because she says
i want a judge
who doesn't have an ideological axe to
grind who is impartial
who is fair
but who doesn't just look at the law
well hold on i thought you wanted a
judge who was impartial who was fair
just like lady justice totally blind
reading the law interpreting the law
treating everyone equally
but also someone who doesn't just read
the law
someone who considers the social
outcomes of decisions well you can't
have both
and she actually catches herself she
realizes in the moment that she's saying
that she wants a judge who won't follow
the law so he says look we yeah we want
to follow the law it's really good they
got to follow the law wouldn't that be
great if they follow it because now
they're not following the law what are
you talking about just insinuating these
things that she doesn't explain then she
says but we need someone who goes beyond
the law
okay
all well and good you have to pick one
you have to pick one you can have a
judge who follows the law and
and pursues justice giving to each what
he deserves
or you can have a judge who is a social
engineer
who merely attempts to figure out what
the most socially
useful outcome will be in this judge's
view on how society should look
and so you ignore the law and you say
okay look if let's say
a
straight white 31 year old man comes
before the court and he broke the same
law that a
uh 52 year old black muslim [ __ ] broke
and they both broke the same law i am
going to maybe put the straight white
guy in jail and i'm going to let the 52
year old black muslim [ __ ] off the
hook because i think that there are too
many
50 year old black muslim midgets in jail
and there aren't enough white guys in
jail so because i'm going to consider
the end result the consequence the end
of of
what's gonna happen in this trial
i'm gonna i'm gonna consider
that and instead of what the law says
okay
fine that's your but you can't have both
you can't have both this goes back to
good old uncle aristotle the law of
non-contradiction you cannot simultane
two things that are contradictory cannot
simultaneously
be true
it's amazing how little
people understand about the supreme
court
and the way the law works and the
judiciary even prominent people
speaking of
tools and sheds and light bulbs and
packs
the women of the view
were just debating
the supreme court nomination
and joy behar and whoopi goldberg
went on some discourse gave some lecture
on the law and the courts that was very
nearly incomprehensible
you know
that somebody like amy coney barrett uh
was put in there
because she's a white woman yeah who
they say well she'll go against abortion
rights and she's a woman oh so that was
deliberate i think clarence thomas a a
black guy a black man a justice okay
i'll give it to him he's a smart guy but
he is to the right of attila the han
this guy and they put him in there
thinking oh a black man will go against
voting rights which is what he does and
it was a terrible and it's a very tricky
business they're pulling over there when
you think about it not to mention the
fact that mitch mcconnell has no concept
of the law when it comes to the supreme
court they know the law they're not
following it right they don't want to
follow when he's allowed to not follow
terribly disrespectful to appoint
someone like clarence thomas with his
philosophies to the seat of thurgood
marshall a civil rights
can anybody tell me
what these hens are clucking about
what on earth are any of these people
talking about
mitch mcconnell he doesn't know anything
about the law yeah mitch mcconnell who's
been in the senate since 1831
one of the most adept parliamentary
geniuses in the history of the us
congress he doesn't know anything about
the law and whoopi goldberg realizes
that what joy behar said doesn't make
any sense and so she says something to
contradict that but that also doesn't
make any sense namely that they know the
law they're just not following the law
what what law are they not following
they have no answer it's just this vague
sort of insinuation
clair amy conibero was put in that
position she's a woman but she was put
in that position to vote against roe
versus wade and clarence thomas he's a
black guy okay i'll give it to him
joy bayer says okay i'll grant he's a
black guy
thank you joy thank you for for giving
clarence thomas his race that's that's
very kind of you
yo cal granny's a black guy sure he's
smart enough but he's bad he's got a bad
judicial philosophy i joy behar who does
not have one 100th the iq of clarence
thomas i am i who have never studied
anything about constitutional law i am
going to pontificate
about what adult clarence thomas is
one of the most accomplished jurists in
the history of the court
he does he's voting against voting
rights
what does that what does that mean
and then the other one i don't even know
her name but the other one on the view
she says yeah and his wife and the
insurrection and the whoopi says that's
a whole show what are you people talking
about you have no idea what you're
talking about
it's just cl clock i don't like this
this is there's a lesson here for
conservatives not merely that if you
want to preserve your your brain cells
you don't tune into this show a show
hosted by five women and four brain
cells it's that's not just the lesson
the lesson is
it is a losing game for conservatives to
play identity politics
it's a losing game we think sometimes we
conservatives we try to get really
clever we say
if we play the game and we
nominate a
i don't know racial minority woman
of a minority religion of this then but
then that person does what we want them
to do
oh that'll that'll own the libs yes
that'll convince that'll prove to them
we're not racist they don't care
what they're insinuating here is that
amy coney barrett isn't really a woman
that clarence thomas isn't really a
black guy sure they might look like a
woman and a black guy but really because
of their beliefs they're not and so and
actually republicans are even more
racist even more sexist for choosing a
woman and a black eye just tune it out
just to go with the best people go with
the best people okay clarence thomas is
not a great jurist because he's a black
guy he's a great jurist because he's
clarence thomas
speaking of different sets of rules
howard stern howard stern the shock jock
par excellence
really a pioneer in the field of shock
jockery
variously obscene
profane
pro-free speech that's what he is he's
anti-censorship
until
until he and his
friends
became the dominant ruling class the
establishment at which point they
defended censorship specifically in the
case
of
neil young trying to get joe rogan
censored from spotify here is
howard stern twisting himself into
logical pretzels to try to defend neil
young without explicitly defending
censorship
i don't think he's for censorship i
don't think
neil young is for censorship i just
think he's saying look i don't want to
be part of this organization
because my music is helping people bring
people to the table and then they're
spreading something as lethal as don't
take the vaccine do this hmm
that makes you know
yeah i you know i'm against any kind of
censorship really you know i really am i
don't like censorship but when you're
talking about life and death like poor
meatloaf got sucked into some weird cult
i'm against all forms of censorship
really i'm against all forms of
censorship
but
you hear that butt
that butt is doing a lot of work there
mr stern
neil young he's not for censorship
neil young just explicitly called to
censor joe rogan on spotify
neil young just said if you don't take
joe rogan off spotify then you don't get
neil young i want all my songs gone and
then then spotify said okay they're gone
i said what
said yeah they're gone
no no guys i'm serious i'm gonna take
all my songs off yeah i know i know we
heard you neil they're gone bye
don't don't let the door hit you guys
come on don't i'm serious yeah okay
right because they weren't gonna stand
for that good for spotify
and now howard stern is defending neil
young and but try but he he's positioned
himself as the anti-censorship guy and
yet now he is overtly
defending censorship
a lot of conservatives are wondering
what happened to these guys
what happened
howard stern was
neil young and crosby stills and nash
they had the free speech tour
in 2006 what happened
uc berkeley all those hippies they had
the free speech movement in the 1960s
what happened
they were all against censorship now
there are the censors
they were never against censorship
they were only against
your censorship
they were never against censorship
they just wanted
to stop your censorship of their stupid
ideas and their perversions
the minute that they
broke
the conservative censorship of their
terrible ideas and their perversions
they reinstituted censorship but it was
a censorship of your good ideas and your
normal flourishing way of behavior that
that's what they did
as i wrote in a a particular book called
speechless controlling words controlling
minds uh where's the bell it's gone okay
that's fine
the battle that we're talking about here
is not a battle between free speech on
the one hand
and censorship on the other
it's a battle between two competing sets
of
standards it's a every society is going
to have taboos every society is going to
have limits
the genius of the free speech movements
and the anti-censorship movements
was that they convinced a society that
we could have absolutely unfettered
license and that would be totally you
could just say whatever but that's
obviously not true that's never been
true in any society ever at least of all
in america
there were always going to be limits
ask howard stern if he supports teaching
the bible in schools you're against
censorship of all sorts right howard
okay so certainly we shouldn't censor
the bible bible from schools
one it's the most important book ever
written from which all of western
civilization springs so
surely you said oh you don't oh that's
so weird i thought you were against
censorship
oh right you won't even support joe
rogan bringing on well-respected medical
experts to discuss
the the major medical public health
questions of our day of course they
support censorship speaking of schools
really bad news out of loudoun county
so you remember in loudoun county daley
white broke this story in loudoun county
a school district covered up a rape that
occurred in a girl's bathroom
a rape perpetrated by a young man who
wore a dress who was confused about his
sex who went into the girl's bathroom
and raped and sodomized a girl then the
school covered it up they they moved him
to another school what happened he did
it again there's actually a third
allegation that he did it he did it a
third time so this kid was sentenced the
judge in this case said that she has
never
put a minor on the sex offender registry
but the details of what he did were so
horrifying that she felt to protect the
public safety she had to put him on the
sex offender registry well another judge
has just reversed that decision
loudoun county judge pamela brooks just
said this court made an error in the
initial ruling the court is not vain
enough to think it's perfect but i want
to get it right and they're taking the
kid off of the sex offender registry
this judge pamela brooks should be
impeached without question this is
deeply unjust conservatives should wield
political power
this is a winning issue first of all
this is
the current governor of virginia glenn
younkin won largely on this issue it's a
winning issue and it's the right thing
to do
speaking of the wrong thing i have to
get to this story i've been meaning to
get to it for a few days now speaking of
the wrong thing to do and the
relationships between men and women
cheryl hines was the wife on curb your
enthusiasm and she's married to rfk jr
who is a generally liberal lawyer he's
the son of robert kennedy robert robert
f kennedy who was assassinated and ran
for president
so rfk has come out and he's made these
comparisons between he's very
anti-vaccine he's very anti-dr fauci and
he's used some lured language and he
compared some of the medical regime to
the holocaust everyone makes holocaust
comparisons i don't really think it's a
great idea but he made it and the wife
comes out and tweets out quote my
husband's reference to anne frank at a
mandate rally in dc was reprehensible
and insensitive the atrocities that
millions endured during the holocaust
should never be compared to anyone or
anything his opinions are not a
reflection of my own in other words yes
i take you to be my husband in sickness
and in health
for good times and bad till death do us
part or until you express a political
view with which i disagree
just a this is a psa for all the young
marriages out there all the young ladies
ladies never do this this is not what a
marriage is you become one flesh
wives submit to your husbands husbands
love your wives i know that's
controversial now to read the the gospel
but you're not pitted against one
another you're not just atomized
individuals either of you
duking it out in public and having to
throw your own husband or your own wife
under the bus don't do it love and
respect one another goodness gracious
if you didn't catch it yet
the latest episode of adam carolla's
daily wire exclusive comedy series truth
yeller is streaming right now it might
just be the best one yet adam takes on
hunter biden and is joined by comedian
tj miller who drops some comedy gold and
proves he's the real deal what do i mean
by that well head on over to
dailywire.com
watch right now to find out go to
dailywire.com subscribe and use code
miller for 25 off your membership get
ready for some serious laughs also if
there's anyone that the biden
administration the mainstream media big
pharma don't want you to hear
it's the voice of dr robert malone
actually the interview that joe rogan
has with robert malone is one of the
reasons why neil young begged
joe rogan to be censored from spotify
he's one of the pioneers of mrna
vaccines he was removed from twitter and
most social media
for his public skepticism of the covid
vaccines
then he went viral on rogan
so you should head on over right now uh
check it out can our very own candace
owen sat down for a three and a half
hour interview with dr malone uh she
does not leave any stone unturned
together they touch on some of the most
alarming statistics questions and trends
that the media and big tech don't want
to acknowledge
it's available exclusively at
dailywire.com this tuesday february 1st
if you don't already have a daily wire
membership join now to catch tuesday's
episode of candace premiering it at 9 pm
eastern 8 pm central we'll be right back
with the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week when i get to hear from you in the
mail bag first question up from arun who
says dear
dr coffey
i think that over the past 23 months you
have had a better take than any other
conservative on the matter of the covet
hoax thank you but among your opinions
my favorite is your belief that we ban
people from wearing masks in public
was this a hypothetical musing or do you
really believe there is a political path
for us to implement a mask ban at the
federal or state levels in my home state
of minnesota we actually have a law on
the books banning face coverings in
public and governor waltz had to
illegally order us to ignore this law
when he mandated masks in our state
could we realistically use laws like
this to prohibit public masking can we
look forward to that glorious day when
karen's are handcuffed in the streets
for covering their faces i'm so glad you
brought this up
because some people seem to think that
i'm kidding when i say
that not only should we not mandate the
masks like the liberals want us to do
not only should we not
uh not only should it be the case that
we should just choose to wear the masks
whether we want to or not like the
sort of squishes and center-right people
want us to do
but actually we should not permit people
with rare exceptions
to wear the masks we should not allow
that in public
and some people think oh michael you're
just being provocative you're just being
to the right of the till of the hun
you're just imagining some law that
could never exist that is so beyond the
bounds of american law
it's already the law
in in a lot of places there are already
laws about this
not only is my position not so far off
the edge of the right my position was
the mainstream position two years ago
you are not
allowed to dress up like a bandito
throughout your entire public life
that's not good
there was a video we played yesterday of
of the comedian liberal comedian michael
rappaport in new york
filming a video of a criminal robbing a
rite aid and just walking out he had a
big mask over his face and no one really
did anything part of the reason that
you're seeing an uptick in these
robberies
is because
people are masking up and so you can't
it's very hard to identify the people
who are doing it
this is not some new technology that
this is what train robbers did in the
wild west
of course i really do believe i know
that sometimes people think i'm
a little more on the right wing side of
things whether it's
you know at our outlet or whether it's
just in the conservative movement i
consider myself a moderate
moderation is a virtue
but
moderate with respect to what
with respect to the law as it stood
throughout most of america two years ago
my view that we should not be allowed to
put our secular kefias on constantly
and our
our medical burkas on everywhere we go
that was the law
and i think we should go back to
enforcing that law from andy
esteemed love guru i've recently joined
a dating site a lovely young lady and i
have been texting here and there for a
couple of weeks and she seems like a
good fit for me so far not to mention
she's cute i don't know if it's going
anywhere since she lives a few hours
away but i'm praying that it does now a
family member wants to introduce me to
one of her friends on a double date on
one hand i'm not actually dating the
girl i'm texting with at this point but
i'm hoping to on the other hand the girl
in the double date situation lives in my
area so we would be able to see each
other much more often if we want to keep
it going is it acceptable to go on the
double date so i don't pass up on an
opportunity to meet someone
or should i only focus on the girl
online in hopes that we do start dating
your advice and any prayers would be
much appreciated sincerely monogamous
yet contemporaneously amorous
go on the date
of course go on to date
you're not married
you're dating and you're not even dating
the girl you're texting you're texting
that girl
if you want to date that girl you should
go date her
but she lives far away all right go
drive
go meet up with her have her visit you
or you visit her
this is
one of the real temptations of our
modern world is we think that time and
space and physicality don't matter at
all
we're all just living in the metaverse
so yeah you're texting this girl and
that
seems like a relationship but it's not a
relationship you don't know this girl
you haven't seen her in person
now maybe you'll hit it off maybe your
soul mates maybe you're meant to be
you and this girl three hours away
you're not going to know that unless you
meet her
you're not going to date her unless you
go on dates with her so so if you want
to do that go do it
but don't allow the
the simulation of a relationship
the virtual
relationship
prevent you from engaging in an actual
relationship i don't like that word
relationship how about love affair how
about courtship how about going to get a
girlfriend how about that kind of thing
absolutely you're not married there's
also a difference between dating and
marriage these days we blur it because
there's obviously so much cohabitation
people just live together in perpetuity
and they don't even ever really get
married
but it's different the rules are
different the stakes are different
your ability to leave
is different
and so
yes we should we should
not treat marriage like dating right we
shouldn't treat marriage like it's the
sort of thing that you can just break up
and walk away and go go
go date somebody else and you know it's
really not a lot of stakes we shouldn't
treat marriage like dating but we also
shouldn't treat dating like marriage
because if dating is treated like
marriage then there's no inducement to
get married
i can pray for you best of luck i hope
you enjoy the dates and find a nice lady
from jessica i'll get straight to the
point i'm glad jessica i don't want you
to beat around the bush she says do guys
care about a woman's body count
not of the murder type oh
okay see let's see what you're getting
at
i know that religious men would find a
low to no body count
would find it or would prefer maybe but
what about the general believes in god
but not a trad and not a total wimp i'll
clean up some of your language as a
majority do guys care sincerely who's
counting
yes
and no
that's not a satisfying answer but i'll
tell you why
yes
guys do care we don't like the idea that
our lady has been
you know around the block many times
okay we like the idea that uh
a woman has some modesty that a woman is
pursuing virtue that a woman is sort of
saving herself maybe just for us even oh
we like that idea so
it would be good not to rack up a
terribly high body count
in the way you're describing it
on the other hand
it's a fallen world people do lots of
bad stuff all have sinned and fall short
of the glory of god in the course of
justice none of us should see salvation
there is redemption there is repentance
people change it's okay we can move on
but i think the key here is the
repentance idea
if you're the sort of lady who
you know has dated every single guy on
the football team you know in the matter
of a month or something
and you haven't changed your ways
then i don't think a man would look very
kindly on that but if you say look when
i was young i mean i was completely nuts
i was a wild child i did all this crazy
stuff sex drugs and rock and roll and
then i realized that was all bad and not
conducive to virtue or a flourishing
life and i completely turned it around
and you know now i'm
going to church and
doing the right thing
then
that's fine
that's good go and sin no more from chad
hey michael love your show i listen
every day thank you
what's keeping the republicans from
getting out in front of the scotus pick
and saying we're really glad the next
nominee will be a black female
and we look forward to condoleezza rice
who is well qualified being the next
nominee thanks so much
that's a good idea
i don't think that would trigger the
libs enough
i don't think it would i mean it would
never happen anyway there's no
non-leftist nominee who has any chance
of of
going going through and actually taking
justice briar's seat
so the only utility in pushing a
candidate on the right is to trigger the
libs
that's the that's the only it's not
going to happen and i just fear that the
libs sort of like condoleezza rice she's
a little more moderate
provost of stanford university for
goodness sakes
i think
if we're going to back a candidate
though i have great great deal of
respect for condoleezza rice
it's got to be candace it's got to be
candace i you know i'll do it right now
i officially endorse
candace
to be the nominee to replace justice
breyer on the court
now i know
that i said at the top of the show
that whoever joe biden picks groped me
at a party in 2003
all right so let's just start that rumor
that's fine from alex what are your
favorite non-fiction and fiction books
the office or parks and rec also nice
transition on thursday seems like
everything is upside down one way to
remedy this upside down world we live in
is to get upside thank you i was proud
of that oh you say yes i can tell you're
particularly proud of that ps do a
transition challenge with two seemingly
unrelated things and see how well you
can transition it examples uh monkeys in
africa and a girl playing with a doll
i would
except i i fear that you're any you've
mentioned
you've mentioned things that are going
to get me in trouble
with political correctness i'm not
you're not allowed to say anything about
africa
that's that will become racist
i don't think you're really allowed to
say anything about girls anymore that
will be sexist and phobic and all sorts
of things so no in the interest of my
show and career i will not do that
transition
because there would be a lot of downside
and i much prefer upside which is why
you should uh get upside i'm sorry what
was your question i don't even remember
what the question oh yes my favorite
fiction and nonfiction books my favorite
fiction book i don't know
in terms of a novel you mean
i guess my favorite novels crime and
punishment my favorite poem is the
divine comedy my favorite
all right let's leave it at that my
favorite non-fiction books
just in no particular order poetic
diction by owen barfield abolition of
man by c.s lewis um
gosh not my favorite
dawn to decadence by jacques barzen i
love that history book
um
symbolism and belief by edwin bevins
kind of a weird little book but i love
that one
oh gosh i don't know the list could go
on and on between the office and parks
and rec that's not even close parks and
rec
from jacob hey michael i was watching
your face the mob episode and you
mentioned that you don't believe bodies
should be cremated can you expand on
this i was not aware this was a part of
catholicism sincerely don't burn me bro
sure i think the catholic church now
permits people to be cremated but i
i'm still against it
i think it makes a mockery of the
resurrection of the body
i think a lot of pagan cultures maybe
most pagan cultures burn their bodies
they dispose of their bodies
zerastering cultures leave them out for
vultures and dogs to eat
christians have traditionally treated
the body in a
in a more respectful way we bury the
body we put the body in a tomb and this
is in no small part because we look
forward to the resurrection of the body
this doesn't mean that the body will not
decay
in most cases
but it just means that we treat the body
in a way that is a little bit more
respectful and a little bit more looking
toward the day when these bones shall
live and jump out of their out of their
graves
the popularity of cremation has really
come about in modernity during a period
of intense anti-christianity and i think
it is it has become popular
in in no small part as as a mockery of
the resurrection so i
wouldn't recommend it from name hey
michael this is nate i have a quick
question about relationships you and
everybody else nate get online i've been
with my girlfriend for what will be two
years in july however we have been best
friends for over three years there is no
question that we are going to get
married but there is a snag to the plan
she will be graduating six months to a
year earlier than i am and moving to
florida with her family i don't know if
i should propose when she graduates and
spend most of our engagement apart or if
i should wait and risk losing the
relationship we've worked so hard for
thank you for your help sincerely nate
pronouns nor slash mole
depends what you're graduating are you
graduating high school or college the
reason i ask is because if you're
it sounds like you're graduating from
high school or she's graduating from
high school because she's saying she's
going to graduate and move to florida
with her family
if she is so if she's
18 i don't really so she'd move to
florida with her family
and then is she going to go to college
maybe she's not going to go to college
okay if she's graduating from college
then why is she going to move with her
family she's 22 years old she's an adult
she can move with her family that's fine
but she's her own person she can also
just go get an apartment she can also
just go live somewhere she can also just
get engaged
why
why wouldn't she
live near you if you're going to be
engaged
i would need more details on this look i
married my high school sweetheart spent
a little bit of time apart but then we
got back together and and so that that's
a wonderful thing and i wish we had
gotten engaged and married sooner
so i'm whether it's a high school or
college
relationship i'm all for it i think
that's great
but
the the snags here are a little
confusing to me
if you're going to do it just do it you
know you don't need your her
you need her father's blessing i suppose
but you don't you don't need anyone's
permission
it
yeah if it's if it's high school you
might be a little young i guess if it's
college though i don't i don't think you
are just go for it all right that's the
show i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show next time you want
me to solve all of your love problems
all you wonderful people out there
i need the details okay that's i need
that's where the real advice is going to
come from i'm michael knowles that's the
michael and hall show see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin